>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, HERE WE
GO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YES, CRAZY PEOPLE.
YOU ARE CRAZY, ALL OF YOU WHAT
YOU DOING HERE?
HAPPY WEDNESDAY YES, IT'S BEEN A
MINUTE SINCE WE LAST TALKED
ABOUT THE COMMANDER WHO GRABS
HIS KHAKIS.
SO LET'S DO IT NOW.
JOE HOW YOU FEELING?
♪ ♪
>> HEY JOE, TOGGLE YOU GET A
HOLE IN YOUR HEAD.
NO THERE IS NO HOLE IT SPELLS
OUT THE FRONT AND THE SIDES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: NICE.
APPARENTLY THE BIG GUY HAS HAD
IT WITH EVERYONE DISGUSTING HIS
ADVANCED AGE.
HE MUST BE USING A MIRACLE
HEALER.
HE'S TIRED OF PEOPLE BRING IT UP
FROM THE CARETAKERS IN
JURASSIC PARK.
ADVANCED AGE IS A PLEASANT WAY
OF SAYING IT IS MADE FROM WOOLLY
MAMMOTH.
JOKES ABOUT JOE'S AGE ARE EASY
ADJUSTING THE JOKES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S TEMPERAMENT
MEMBER?
FROM SAID THAT WE GET TIRED OF
WINNING, AND JOE'S BRAIN CELLS
IN CAP THINNING.
[LAUGHS]
BUT AS THEY REPORT THE PRESIDENT
HAS VENTED TO ALLIES ABOUT HOW
OFTEN HIS AGE IS MENTIONED IN
THE PRESS.
INCLUDE THE PRESIDENT TO THINK I
DON'T KNOW HOW [BLEEP] OLD I AM?
HE SAID TO ONE EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
WHICH THE REPORTER REPLIED, SIR
THAT IS A LAMP.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M OVER HERE MR. PRESIDENT THE
SAD FACT IS JOE WE DO THINK YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW OLD YOU ARE A
MINORITY YOU KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
AND HOW TO EXIT FROM A STAGE AND
WHO YOUR GRANDCHILDREN ARE.
AT 80 HE IS THE OLDEST PRESIDENT
TO EVER WET LINCOLN'S BED.
[LAUGHTER]
AT LEAST BY ACCIDENT.
SHADOW BILL CLINTON.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU ARE SICK PEOPLE.
HE CERTAINLY IS THE FIRST TO
CONFUSE HIS SISTER FOR HIS WIFE
SURE SOMETIME SO CONFUSE THE
KITCHEN FOR THE BATHROOM WHICH
EXPLAINS WHY JILL KEEPS HER ROLL
OF TOILET PAPER NEXT TO THE
WAFFLE IRON.
WHY SHE OFTEN FINDS A PANCAKE
BATTER HAIRBRUSHES.
JUST THIS WEEK WE WERE WITNESS
TO THE LATEST CONFUSED MESS ON
MONDAY AT AT TOYS FOR TOTS EVENT
IS JOE REFERS TO IT THE
PARADISE.
THE PREZ NEEDED SOME GUIDANCE.
♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT A CHILD COURSED A MAN INTO
A VAN.
STILL IT IS REFRESHING TO SEE A
CHILD LEADING A DEMOCRAT AND NOT
A DEMOCRAT LEADING A CHILD TO A
GENDER REASSIGNMENT CLINIC.
HE ENDED UP WITH A CHILD'S TOY
BICYCLE AS HE WON'T HAVE TO FALL
AS FAR FROM THAT ONE.
TRIED TO MOUNT IT, THE LEAST
THEY COULD DO IS LEAVE THE
TRAINING WHEELS ON.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WOW I HAVEN'T SEEN
AMOUNT THAT AWKWARD SINCE I FELL
ASLEEP IN THE WOODS.
MY FAVORITE CHRISTMAS.
DOESN'T JOE BIDEN REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED THE LAST TIME HE MET
THE BIKE?
♪ ♪
>> Greg: IF YOU WANT TO HIT
HIS HEAD IT MIGHT HELP HIS
MEMORY.
UNDOUBTEDLY FOR THE PRESENT WE
REMEMBER THE PAST DIFFERENTLY WE
SAW HIM FALL OFF OF A BIKE HERE
MEMBERS RIDING IN
TOUR de FRANCE.
WITH ONE POT.
AND JOE WAS ON MORE MEDS THAN
LANCE ARMSTRONG, LIKE BEING OLD
IS A GOOD PLACE TO BE IN LIFE I
LOVE IT.
AT LEAST FOR YOU, BUT NOT THE
COUNTRY YOU GOVERN OR THE BUS
THAT YOU'RE DRIVING.
SURE IT'S FUN AND GAMES AND
LEATHER JACKETS AND AVIATORS,
THAT'S WHERE THE COLUMN TOP
GUMS.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WONDER IF
THEY RENDER THE COUNTRIES IN THE
HE SPENDS 80% OF HIS DAY, BOTTOM
LINE PEOPLE WANT TO MOUNT A NEW
POLL SHOWS THAT 50% OF VOTERS DO
NOT WANT JOE TO RUN AGAIN FOR
THAT VERY REASON.
AND ONLY 30 PERCENT DO WANT HIM
TO GIVE IT ANOTHER GO.
12% JUST WANT HIM TO STOP
LICKING THEIR HAIR.
IN A GROUP TO THE LEFT OF THEM
WANT HIM OUT.
SHE GOES ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN OF THE WHITE HOUSE IN
2024.
>> I'M CONCERT WITH JOE BIDEN'S
LOW POLLING.
>> IT'S WAY TOO MUCH OF A
GAMBLE.
>> THE ELECTION IS AT SERIOUS
RISK.
>> JOE BIDEN.
>> WE CAN'T AFFORD THE REST OF
THE WHITE HOUSE TO BE REPUBLICAN
WHICH WOULD GO AGAINST THE
STATUS QUO.
>> JOE BIDEN RUNNING UNDERMINES
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S CHANCES
IN 2024.
>> WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE.
>> DON'T RUN JOE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: I WONDER WHICH
STARBUCKS THEY HAD TO GO TO GET
ALL THOSE ACTORS.
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING GOOD
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S SITTING
INTO HIS NINTH DECADE.
FOR ONE IS ONLY SO MUCH THAT YOU
CAN DO IN A DAY AND THEN AGAIN
YOU COULD SAY THE SAME THING IN
OPEN CASKETS.
OLD FOLKS ALSO HAVE CHARMING
YARNS TO UNRAVEL ALTHOUGH JOE
NEVER MAKES IT ANYWHERE.
>> President Biden: EVEN HOLES
NEAR AND DEAR TO YOU A LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ANYWAY.
WHEN THEY LEAVE THE SALON
RECEPTIONIST SALOON SALON MAY BE
GOING TO SALOON ON A NO.
AMERICA'S A NATION THAT CAN BE
DEFINED IN A SINGLE WORLD.
.WHEN I DOING HERE?
[LAUGHS]
YEAH, [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: I KNOW, IT'S TOO EASY
TO HIT HIM FOR HIS AGE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE STILL EFFECTIVE
DESPITE THEIR ADVANCE AGE AND
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER THINGS
WE COULD HIT HIM ON NOT JUST A
NUMBER.
BUT IS IT OUR FAULT THAT WE HAD
ON THE OBVIOUS?
ON REMEMBER ANY OF THE OTHER
LATE-NIGHT HOST PUMP AND THE
BRAKES WHEN HE CAME TO RIPPING
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT IS NOT A BIG DEAL, EVEN ALL
NOT EVEN SURE IF IT'S BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
BEING OLD IS IN YOUR BIGGEST
PROBLEM AS LONG AS YOUR OWN GOOD
AND SMART AND CAPABLE PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE HERE.
YES RUN BY YOUNGER PEOPLE
INFECTED WITH WOKENESS DETACH
FROM REAL LIFE.
ARROGANT, INEXPERIENCED, AND ARE
ANGRY THEY WANT TO CHANGE
AMERICA NOT FOR THE BETTER.
SO JOE MAY BE OLD, BUT THEY ARE
KIND OF DANGEROUS.
SALLY ITSY ADVANCE AGE THAT
WOULD SOME ROLL RIGHT OVER HIM
LIKE A SPEED BUMP WITH DENTURES.
IT'S TOO EASY TO BLAME JOE BIDEN
FOR EVERYTHING, BUT IT'S REALLY
THE PEOPLE RUNNING THE SHOW AND
THEY ARE SO YOUNG THEY COULD
SHARE A DIAPER WITH THEM.
THE LESSON HERE IS NOT IT WAS
THE PRESIDENT WHO MATTERS, IT'S
WHO WAS PULLING THE STRINGS.
AS LONG AS HE IS A GOOD
BREAKFAST, GOOD MORNING BM AND
SOMEONE READ HIM HIGHLIGHTS AND
BEDTIMES, JOE BIDEN IS FINE WITH
THE TUG FROM ABOVE.
SO TAKE US HOME IF YOU COULD
FIND IT.
>> NO, NO LOOK.
GUYS HAVE MADE TO NEVER DREAM OF
DOING.
THE ECONOMY IS DOWN, GAS PRICES
ARE UP INFLATION IS UP, A
4-YEAR-OLD WHO CAN DO ALL THAT.
I LOVE THE 80s.
IT'S ABOUT ME.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME
TONIGHT'S GUESTS, HER KNOWLEDGE
OF THE MARKET WILL FILL YOUR
POCKETS, HOST ON FOX BUSINESS,
MARIA BARTIROMO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SHE KNOWS AS MUCH ABOUT
ELECTIONS AS I KNOW ABOUT
REJECTIONS.
REVOKE AND STRATEGISTS,
ERIN PERRINE.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE ONCE TOLD FROSTY THE SNOWMAN
TO CHILL OUT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
A SLEEPING BAG AS HIS CHRISTMAS
STOCKING, MY MASSIVE PSYCHIC AND
THE N.W.A. WORLD HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: IT IS A PLEASURE TO
HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW, THIS THE
FIRST TIME EVER IS IN A QUESTION
MARK >> Maria: I KNOW, I'M SO
HAPPY TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
>> Greg: ARE YOU REALLY HAPPY?
>> Maria: A BIT MUCH BUT EVERY
NIGHT YOU KNOW IT'S PAST MY
BEDTIME.
I'M THINKING I REALLY WANT TO GO
ON THAT SHOW BECAUSE YOU ADVISED
ME WHEN YOU FIRST STARTED AND IT
DIDN'T WORK OUT.
>> Greg: YOU SAID NOT ON YOUR
LIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU SAID I DO KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
PLEASE LEAVE MY OFFICE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
GRANTED I WASN'T WEARING PANTS.
[LAUGHTER]
IS A JOE'S AGE WHERE THE PEOPLE
BEHIND THE SCENES?
>> Maria: I DON'T THINK IT'S
THE AGE, I ACTUALLY THINK HE HAS
ISSUES.
I THINK I'M NOT A DOCTOR BUT ARE
SPOKEN TO DOCTORS.
[LAUGHTER]
OCCURRENCE WHEN JACKSON SAYS
THAT HE HAS DEMENTIA.
IT'S SAD ACTUALLY.
IT'S NOT FUNNY I'M THINK IT'S
HIS AGE.
I THINK HIS MENTAL LIMITATIONS.
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE FOR
PEOPLE TO AGNES B. FROM TV.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Maria: THAT'S WHY I'M NOT A
DOCTOR.
>> Greg: DO YOU NEED TO BE A
DOCTOR THESE DAYS TO DIAGNOSE
ILLNESSES?
YOU GOT WIKIPEDIA, UNLIKE SO
AHEAD OF MY DOCTOR WHEN I GO
THERE, ARTIE KNOW WHAT I HAVE.
HAVE ALREADY PICTURES OF IT AND
ABSENTED TO DR. SIEGEL, BY THE
TIME I SHOWPIECE SICK OF SEEING
WHATEVER I HAVE.
>> Maria: I THINK IT'S A
PROBLEM, YOU HAVE OTHERS LIKE
ADVERSARIES WATCHING WHAT WE ARE
WATCHING AND IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
VOTERS, THAT IS YOUR WHEELHOUSE.
THEY MEANS EXPERTISE.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT ARE VOTERS, THE VOTERS BE
MORE MOVED BY POLICIES OR BY HIS
AGE OR EVEN MAYBE HIS HEALTH
STATUS?
>> Erin: I THINK IS TO BE
MOVED BY HIS AGE BECAUSE OF A
NEW CUBES COULD BE OLD WHEN HE
ELECTED THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE,
BUT I THINK THERE'S ANY REAL
CLEAR INDICATION ABOUT EVEN WITH
THAT AT SAINT DON'T RUN, HE IS
AIMING TO RUN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
RULES RIGHT NOW TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR JOE BIDEN IN THE
PRIMARY PROCESS TO RUN.
PUTTING SELF: A FIRST WITH
DEMOCRATS AND FLOODED.
THAT'S PAYBACK TO GOOD OLD JIM
CLYBURN HOUSE MEMBER WHO HELP
JOE BIDEN WIN THAT STATE IT'S A
STATE THAT FAVORS THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THAT IS NOT A
SWING STATE THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T
ABOUT TO WIN SOUTH CAROLINA THAT
SETTING IT UP FOR JOE BIDEN WINS
AGAIN AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
HIS AGE OF THE PEOPLE BEHIND THE
SCENES, THE GUYS CAN RUN AGAIN
IN 24 AND IT'S A MIX OF ALL THE
TOGETHER THAT'S CAUSING A
DISASTER THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
LIVING THROUGH.
>> Greg: WANTED SO STRANGE
BECAUSE IT SEEMED SO HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT WHEN PEOPLE SAYING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IT'S LIKE
OH, YEAH, MAYBE THEY COULD
HAPPEN.
IT'S A TIME FOR LIKE A PUBLIC
TEST A LEADER SHOULD TAKE SO WE
CAN SEE HOW THEY TRULY FUNCTION?
SPEED TO KNOW, BECAUSE WE KNOW
NOW AS IT MATTER.
[LAUGHS]
>> Kat: YOU DON'T TO TAKE A
TEST I WANT TO KNOW THE PERSON
SAID WHEN HE SAID DO THEY THINK
I DON'T KNOW HOW [BLEEP] OLD I
AM?
WILL KIND OF.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT PERSON WORKS WITH THEM SO
THEY SEE MORE THAN WE DO.
AND IF YOU CONSIDER THE STUFF
THAT WE DO SEE, WHAT ARE THEY
SAYING?
HOW DO THEY REPLY THAT QUESTION?
AS I JUST A BUNCH OF OTHER
PEOPLE, YET HE CAN DO DOING A
GREAT JOB THEY MUST BE BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO THINK THAT
THERE'S ANY PROBLEM.
>> Greg: THAT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE WHAT DO THEY SEE, VERSUS
WHAT DO WE SEE?
MAYBE STEVE DOOCY, OR
PETER DOOCY CAN FIND OUT WHAT
THEY DON'T SEE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
ALL YOU GUYS.
YOU'RE DEAFLY IN THE HOLIDAY
SPIRIT.
AL'S TOTAL CHARITY CLAPPING.
SO HERE'S THE THING ABOUT THE
AGE QUESTION, THIS WILL, TRUST
ME NUTS, I DON'T THINK THAT JOE
WAS NOTHING SPECIAL 20 YEARS AGO
OR 30 YEARS AGO OR 40 YEARS AGO.
HERE'S A TYPICAL HACK,
ESTABLISHMENT POLITICIAN GO
ALONG TO GET ALONG HE JUST LOVE
THE PERKS OF BEING A POLITICIAN.
>> Tyrus: AND I THINK HE'S
LIKE IN THE PERKS OF BEING A
POLITICIAN IS THE SAME BEHAVIOR,
I THINK THE AGE THINK IT'S HIM A
CUSHION.
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS TO ATTACK
THE AGE THING, NO ONE WAS TO BE
LIKE WE COLEMAN AGES?
WORLD IS TRYING TO FOCUS ON OUR
RACES AND WE DON'T TIME TO JUMP
INTO AGEISM.
AS TO FOR ME.
HE GETS A PASS BECAUSE I DO
THINK IT'S THAT BECAUSE THE VP
CAN'T SPEAK EITHER.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: AT THE PLAY MUSIC TO
CONVINCE YOURSELF THAT SHE HAS A
POET MESSING WITH US.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S LIKE THEY DON'T PREPARE AND
HE JUST GOES, THE ONE THING THAT
HAS BEEN CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT
HIS ENTIRE POLITICAL CAREER HE
GOES WHAT'S EVER GOOD FOR JOE.
AND RIGHT NOW HE SEEMS TO FEEL
TO THE PROGRESSIVE WAY IS HIS
WAY.
HE DOESN'T READ THE
TELEPROMPTERS.
THEY RUN IT, HE DOES IT AND THEN
IT'LL MESS THEM UP IS LIKE AND
BE LIKE OH, HE'S OLD.
NO HE'S INCOMPETENT.
I WAS UP EVERY NIGHT AND EVERY
TIME YOU WANT SMELLS LIKE.
WILL YOU KNOW YOU GOT TO DO WHAT
YOU GOT TO DO DOG YOU KNOW TO
MEAN?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUS